riki this was your first feature film
feature film your first starring role
tell me about yes shout it out for Ricki
Lake so uh Toby tell me about meeting
meeting John and coming in to audition
for this I mean I was a freshman a
musical theater freshman at Ithaca
College and I was hating it and I'd
heard about a local audition they were
looking at for a fat girl uka dance was
a John Waters move John Waters movie
with Devine and I didn't know who either
of them were so I went and drove down
during finals week met him on the first
audition I was wearing a big the biggest
hits ever and I was wearing this giant
it's like a college sweatshirt and the
whole time he was trying to assess
whether I was really big or I was padded
and and and I had one callback and and
that was it I mean I you know I didn't
know what I was getting into which I
think was what helped because I wasn't
nervous I didn't know who this crew were
I did mother knew right my mother was a
little scared but she she I was 18 and I
was on my own but I yeah it was the
summer of my life and honestly I have
this movie and John to thank for my
entire career so thank you well thank
you thank you and I always said if a
very few girls at that time came to
tryout but a 10,000 had tried out Ricky
we still would have gotten apart you
would have you would have John I read an
interview with John said that Devine
wanted to play basically every role in
the film including yours so what was it
like working with Devon he did not like
me in the beginning what is your part
right he was jealous um and so he yeah
he was sussing me out and he was like
you know he really really felt like it
was appropriate for him to play Tracy
and the mom but he warmed up to me and
he gave me a lot of pointers do you
remember that time in his hotel room
when he was dragging he's like you're
not doing it right this is how you're
walking heals you know yeah yeah and and
then and then he really did like me and
bonded yeah and we bonded over food
he loved to share food with me he would
say Ricky let's share a pie let's eat a
roast
let's see the room and I obliged but
also Ricky kept losing weight we were
filming from although exercise so she'd
come around the corner of fat continuity
was thirty pounds off in the movie so we
had to give her dove bars between each
takes father your Rat Patrol yeah yeah
Pat ran Henny Garfunkel yeah
here eat the stop bar yeah